this episode is sponsored by google play
with the help of summoner's war lost
interior
[Music]
from the streaming service with the
biggest gap between quality of content
and suckage of interface comes marvel's
latest avengers you didn't really care
about
until they got their own tv show the
falcon and the winter soldier
who's next hawkeye of course
when a rogue super soldier is on the
loose the only thing that can stop her
is a few shots from a regular gun
but since this story has to last six
episodes two of marvel's weakest heroes
are on the case sam the falcon wilson
a man with the power of a jet pack he
rents from the air force
and bucky the winter soldier barnes
proof that men will literally scour the
criminal safe haven of magipore
instead of going to therapy you missed
your court mandated therapy
sorry mr barnes you're under arrest but
when these not even that opposite
military guys have to work together
you'll be in for a lot of forced
bickering that's not a thing
that's definitely no it's not a lot of
forced quips
now that falcon is technically the funny
one and he mastered posing stoic
and so much forced talk about cap's old
shield that you'll start to wish cat was
short for please decapitate me
thank you captain america but this
belongs to you
let's take the shield and do this
ourselves you got to give me the shield
man
he gave you that shield for a reason
why'd you give up that shield he had no
right to give up the shield sam
shouldn't have given him the shield
i didn't give him the shield that
shield's the closest thing i've got left
to a family
it's just a shield bro don't lose your
arm over it
you know you think you would know that
there's a button that pops his arm off i
mean doesn't he even play with that
thing
return to the military espionage side of
the mcu
where the morals are as gray as the
visuals full of shady characters
like semo a fancy dancer
who talks about the black experience one
too many times for someone who blew up
the king of wakanda
i told him about trouble man he wrote in
that book it is a masterpiece james
it captures the african-american
experience
sharon carter who's grown bitter and
resentful since the man she stalked for
a living went back in time to bang her
great aunt
and john walker the heir apparent to the
kool-aid guy
oh yeah he may look the part but this
blond-haired honk still isn't ready to
take on the mantle of america's next
kurt russell
also julie louie dreyfus pops up at the
end because everyone in hollywood is
obligated to join the mcu at this point
your next costanza this whole universe
is against me
no one will escape the fury of the flag
smashers a movement with a nefarious
plan
to deliver food and medicine to refugees
but don't worry
they'll kill just enough people to
qualify as villains i agree
with your fight i just can't give it the
way you're fighting it you tell him
falcon
she needs to join the military first
that's the mcu's license to kill
to combat his rising threat of poor
people having nowhere to live
sam must become a new kind of captain
america
one who will call out the problems with
our system look you people have just
as much power as an insane god then ask
them to
do better and hope that it changes
anything you've got to do better senator
honestly the fact that this speech works
is the least realistic part of the mcu
and they share a universe with this guy
[Music]
so enjoy a show that feels like a
stretched out beat to your marvel movie
that annoyingly makes you stay up late
to watch every episode unless you want
it spoiled on twitter
ah dang it in this enjoyable series that
deepens existing characters
bring some big budget action to the
small screen
and add crucial new information to the
marvel universe
the avengers don't get paid how do you
guys make a living
there's a tremendous amount of goodwill
right but you could have been living off
of goodwill this whole time
we cannot approve you is there some kind
of fun for heroes or
so this is why scarlet witch drives a
buick
starring the black falcon was denied a
bank loan
i stan sebastian barron's dance grooves
the carter two a wolf in veep's clothing
goldie spawn just when i thought this
country couldn't get any meaner
you go and do something like this and
totally redeem yourself
power punch girl oh it's those antivas
super soldiers i've been hearing about
and sam's on the boat
sends on a boat everybody look at sam
cause he's sailing on a boat
sam's on the boat sam's on a boat take a
good hard look
at sam's sister's parents boat sky
captain
and the shield of tomorrow
let's do it let's stare they're
practically begging us to do a stairs
montage huh
[Music]
are you having a staring contest the
bionic staring machine
is always a stare like that wait cut the
music
no no no no you can't stare bait us like
that your stairs are too forced stairs
have to be natural
you're doing the staring thing again hey
screen junkies
may the fourth be with you check out the
new show rabbit hole where we find the
hidden connections in film and tv
up first how darth vader was created by
shrooms
no seriously mushrooms are the key to
all of star wars
check it out this episode is sponsored
by google play
download summoner's war lost interior
and discover more on google play now
there are very few please say comments
nowadays
say these violent delights have violent
hands
it feels too good i can't stop
scratching it click the stamp
and send it